I'm throwing a party later  don't tell király if you want this thing  to go off you need my help and I want  half are you threatening me you don't go  and be a whiny little [ __ ] and cried to  Carell about the party  maybe I'll introduce you to Vinnie  tonight he's no agent touch me  this god only knows what kind of mold  and parasites live between your legs and  all about well now that I know what you  up to that little cute designer purse  it's mine and if you want a little  fiesta go friend hitch fees on my tarts  old lady Clairol who manages this place  I don't think she's gonna be cool with  us having a party here last minute what  I care about is my money my time if you  don't come through you're gonna face a  storm of unimaginable  yeah coming soon